[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi 15
mars c'est en ce moment la semaine de la
persévérance scolaire dans toute
l'académie de versailles elle a pour
objectif de lutter contre le décrochage
des élèves et des animations se tiennent
dans plusieurs établissements comme au
collège anatole-france aux clayes sous
bois et qui met en avant ses talents
reportage avec le temps qui passe et la
réglementation qui évolue difficile de
se souvenir parfaitement du code de la
route à magny les hameaux un atelier de
révision pour les seniors se tenait hier
une initiative de la commune pour
permettre également de rappeler quelques
bons réflexes
enfin les passionnés de modélisme ont
rendez vous ce week end à montigny le
bretonneux une exposition de bateaux et
de train en miniature est au programme à
la salle paul gauguin avoir notamment un
réseau ferroviaire de 50 m² et deux
invités à suivre également dans ce
journal mathieu slash est directeur du
centre de formation professionnelle
continue en ostéopathie instructeurs de
la méthode
wemhoff qu'une méthode pour résister au
froid extrême on en parle tout à l'heure
et puis jean armel catelin président du
comité des fêtes de coignières
l'association organise ce week end une
nouvelle édition de la fête de la bière
une centaine de personnes mobilisées à
paris ce jeudi après-midi les personnels
des ehpad ces établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes étaient dans la rue alors
qu'une réforme du financement de ces
centres est en préparation et les
manifestants réclament plus de moyens
notamment humains un manque de personnel
qui réduit selon les syndicats et
l'efficacité du travail au sein des
ehpad
écoutez à ce propos christophe salomon
de la cfdt santé sociaux des yvelines
interrogé par mélanie poquet on a un
turnover trêve important du personnel
due au fait qu' il ne réussit pas à
remplir leurs tâches comme il le
voudrait pour savoir que dans les ehpad
ils peuvent avoir jusqu'à 14 peut l'être
à faire pendant la matinée on arrive
toujours à la fin personne est une colle
est maintenant voir ce que l'on appelle
une trêve dans ces cas-là fois une
délégation a été reçue cet après midi
par la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
le mouvement devrait se poursuivre se
mettre à chanter danser ou jouer d'un
instrument devant ses camarades
l'épreuve n'était évidemment pas simple
pour les collégiens c'est à ce propos
c'est ce que propose un depuis plusieurs
années un établissement des
clayes-sous-bois les jeunes sont invités
à dévoiler leur talent une initiative
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
semaine de la persévérance scolaire dans
les yvelines
l'objectif c'est de lutter contre le
décrochage des élèves reportage de
nicolas kirillovitch le temps de la
pause déjeuner le préau du collège s'est
transformé en scènes pour jeunes talents
[Musique]
héloïse amélie et claudia sont en 4e
elle s'entraîne depuis plusieurs jours
pour danser devant leurs camarades
si le lieu est original le public lui
peut se révéler intimidant j'en aï c'est
super ils applaudissent to say i rigole
dans tout ça mais après il y en a aussi
qui critiquent et ça
après mais enfin ça c'est très bien
d'acidité
depuis six ans le collège anatole france
participe à la semaine de la
persévérance à l'école dans les yvelines
un temps fort pour mettre en avant les
compétences inconnu et caché des élèves
et favoriser leur réussite scolaire il
ça permet aux enseignants et aux élèves
de voir les élèves autrement quand un
élève qu en échec quand il nous montre
ce qu'il est capable de faire
nous aussi on a un autre regard sur ce
qu'il est capable de faire et de le
valoriser
ça peut être des points d'appui fort
justement l aider mais dans sa scolarité
ce midi là pendant une demi heure les
prestations s'enchaînent de la danse et
du chant devant des camarades qui sont
conquis et julien dans le rôle de
l'animateur qui ont tu vois à quel point
ça plaît aux élèves ça les rassure et
x10
à la fin on peut citer application qui
peut avoir saisi ce j'ai réussi c'était
très bien et ils repartent en cours avec
un grand sourire et c'est ça qui est
bien un grand sourire pour reprendre les
cours et pour certains l'envi peut être
de faire quand ils seront grands
carrière sur scène un député du var hier
jeudi hier mercredi dans les yvelines
pardon va fabien à matra c'était à la
caserne de rambouillet il a rencontré
les pompiers volontaires de ce centre de
secours en compagnie de la députée de la
circonscription aurore bergé
le parlementaire et les rues mc vu
justement confié en décembre une mission
gouvernementale sur le sujet par le
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
ce mois ci il doit remettre un rapport
pour jeter les bases d'un plan de
relance du volontariat chez les pompiers
le nombre d'engagés a tendance à stagner
depuis quelques années ces chiffres
datent de 2000 16 500 personnes de plus
de 75 ans sont décédés dans un accident
de la route en tant que conducteur ou
passager à pied aussi les risques
existent un piéton tué sur deux a plus
de 65 ans à des statistiques alarmantes
à magny les hameaux un atelier s'est
tenu hier pour permettre aux seniors de
réviser leur code de la route et d'être
conseillés sur les bons réflexes à
adopter au volant mélanie poquet patrick
jacques de dixmude et quentin le frère
pour cette manie croiser la voiture est
indispensable mais après plus de 40 ans
de conduite
elle sait que ses connaissances ne sont
plus les mêmes j'ai passé mon printemps
1971 et donc je pense qu une très nette
évolution et je vais me remettre au goût
du jour parce que je roule quand même
pas mal
et puis bon je pense qu'on en a besoin
passé un certain âge de se remettre en
question et de voir qu'est ce qu'il nous
reste une remise au goût du jour à
l'hôtel de ville
magny les hameaux organise un atelier
code de la route à destination des
seniors
au programme des rappels et les
nouvelles réglementations de 2015 et
c'était aussi nous demande de la police
municipale la force de patrouiller les
constatation de l'infraction
voilà on soit 104 soit aussi que les
règles de base sont complètement oubliés
ou ou
carrément les ateliers on arrive à avoir
ces vingt trente personnes
exceptionnellement et on est à plus de
50 personnes donc c'est vraiment une
réelle demande des seniors et la plupart
conduisons ceux qui sont là en france 17
% de la population a plus de 65 ans une
catégorie d'âge sur représentés dans les
chiffres de la sécurité routière
vous l'avez vécu la france et le
département des yvelines ont fait face à
une vague de froid en ce début d'année
est les thermomètres sont descendues
jusqu'à -10° alors si certains ont pu
avoir peur de ces températures glaciales
d'autres au contraire les recherches les
adeptes de la méthode
wemhoff du nom d'un néerlandais appelés
également l'homme de glace le concept
apprendre à maîtriser son corps pour
accepter le froid avec des respirations
les détails avec ce sujet de michael et
demi d'euros une dizaine de minutes de
longue respiration une série de pompes
avant un bain dans de l'eau glacée avec
un bonnet pour conserver la chaleur
ces deux têtes je les applique depuis un
an la méthode wemhoff du nom d'un
néerlandais de 58 ans sur le 1000 hommes
de glace après cinq minutes dans l'eau
premier réaction ce qu'on ressent c'est
que c'est justement le fait qu'on soit
focalisée sur son souffle va te
permettre en fait d'apprécier
bizarrement le le côté vivifiant de
l'eau et le côté froid donc elle est
vraiment forte tu le sens le sent tout
de suite aux extrémités c'est ça le le
premier point faible entre guillemets en
fait qu'on va avoir c'est d'être imités
que ce soit les pieds les mains accepter
le froid et ne pas résister deux
principes enseignés avant de se lancer
par cinq instructeurs en france dont 1
dans les yvelines les méthodes proches
du yoga peuvent être expliqués en huit
journées aux personnes en bonne santé
médicale d'une attitude corporelle
relâche et des épaules
il ya une attitude à travers la
respiration c'est à dire si on rentre
dans l'eau sans entraînement on va être
complètement paniqué c'est à dire que le
cerveau passe en mode peurs primales ne
peux pas le contrôler de l'inspiration
en reprendre le contrôle et
et calmer le jeu pour que le corps
s'adapte et laisse faire ce qui doit se
faire selon les théoriciens de cette
méthode le système immunitaire serait
renforcée suite à cette exposition au
froid
au total cette discipline recense près
de 150000 à 200000 adeptes à travers le
monde et notamment aux états-unis en
australie dans les yvelines seulement
une dizaine de pratiquants sont recensés
et pour parler de cette méthode
justement vous l'avez vu dans ce
reportage mathieu slash est bonsoir
bonsoir à vous êtes le directeur du
centre de formation professionnelle
continue en ostéopathie vous êtes
instructeur de cette méthode
wemhoff originaire des yvelines vous
êtes originaire des yvelines
la méthode elle est originaire de des
pays bas parce que technicien
néerlandais de 58 ans oui bof c'est le
nom d'un néerlandais de 58 ans avec est
surnommé l'homme de glace et qui détient
plusieurs records du monde
on n'a plus eu plus d'une vingtaine
d'accords voilà et pour lui l'histoire a
commencé très jeune ce qu'il a découvert
la les atouts du froid à l'âge de 19 ans
puis après il n'a cessé d'être en
recherche et ce qui a précipité le
l'histoire c'est que sa femme souffrait
de bipolarité
malheureusement elle s'est
malheureusement suicidé laissant avec
quatre enfants et ça l'a incité à
poursuivre ses recherches de façon
beaucoup plus approfondie et puis
jusqu'à l'émergence récente qu'on a eu
et tous les événements scientifiques ont
lieu autour de cette méthode
alors oui bof prétend avoir une
concentration de graisse brune plus
développé que la moyenne
cette graisse brune qui permet à l'être
humain finalement de de faire face au
froid puisque ça génère de la chaleur à
la grèce oui c'est vrai quand le bébé né
il est équipé de deux types de graisses
les graisses blanche et les graisses
brunes tout le monde connaît les
graisses blanche
on cherche plutôt à se débarrasser et
ses graisses brunes elles ont la
capacité de générer de la chaleur
et aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'espoir
qui sont d'espoir médicaux qui sont mis
autour de ces graisses brunes parce que
en
en s'exposant au froid le froid c'est à
partir de 18 2 secondes on peut en fait
renverser le phénomène et faire en sorte
que les graisses blanche se transforme
en graisse brune ce qui nous aiderait à
lutter contre l'obésité également le
diabète de type 2 comment vous avez
connu cette méthode wemhoff qu'est ce
qui vous a plu et qu'est ce qui vous a
touché dans la méthode wemhoff justement
je suis un mois je suis un sportif
passionné d'arts martiaux de sports
nautiques et puis j'ai eu une grosse
blessure qui m'a emmené sur plein de
chemin de recherche personnelle et j'ai
été très touché par certaines choses que
j'ai découvert dans les arts martiaux
russe je fais également instructeur de
systèmes en d'accord donc j'ai découvert
le froid en russie sous d'autres aspects
ça m'a fait des choses à l'intérieur que
j'ai mis très longtemps à comprendre une
dizaine d'années et on commence à me
documenter donc j'ai appris l'existence
de vim
j'ai regardé ses documentaires qui sont
en accès libre sur internet et j'ai
décidé d'aller rencontrer pour voir
voilà s'il y avait une cohérence entre
les discours de l'homme qui ils étaient
ce qu'il faisait
et c'est vrai que c'est essentiellement
changé ma vie mon permis de mieux me
connaître de mieux récupérer
et puis de guider les autres en prenant
ce vilain du coup d'essayer
on dit vim ma vie mais c'est son prénom
et offs et 123 alors avec avec cette
prononciation vimov la méthode vie maaf
on l'a vu dans le reportage une méthode
pour faire face au froid escalader des
bénéfices vous en avez parlé des
bénéfices sur la santé cette méthode
énormément de bénéfices
anas et non plus oui il ya des il ya des
indications des grandes indications mais
énormément de bénéfices d'abord de façon
très générale on apprend à augmenter ses
capacités d'adaptation
très souvent quand on va dans des
ateliers vimov les gens ils demandent
combien de temps tu es resté dans l'eau
et à quelle température s'était en fait
c'est les questions compaq ont pas de
sens l'important c'est plutôt de
travailler la variabilité donc on va
s'exposer à plein de moments de plein de
façons différentes à plein de
température différente donc déjà on
augmente ses capacités d'adaptation
deuxièmement on apprend à piloter
certaines de ces hormones notamment
l'adrénaline qui est une des hormones
maîtresse dans le phénomène de stress
donc plutôt la piloter que la subir et
deuxièmement troisièmement pardon on va
également pouvoir déclencher et
optimiser c'était une réaction du
système immunitaire
on a tendance à dire par exemple quand
on prend une douche froide que la
circulation sanguine et et facilité est
ce que c'est le cas ça c'est un point
très important c'est vrai que dans le
corps humain on a quand même 120 mille
kilomètres d'un cent vingt mille
kilomètres de vaisseau qui soit artères
et veines et lymphatique et c'est vrai
qu'en travaillant avec ses variations de
température en appelons aux muscles qui
sont autour de ses tubes artérielle
veineux et c'est à se contracter de
façon plus intelligente ce donc on
travaille en fait tout tout tout notre
système vasculaire
alors pour pratiquer cette méthode il
faut être bien sûr encadrés par des
professionnels ça c'est important
c'était précisant le reportage
d'ailleurs la préparation est ultra
importante on l'a vu bien préparer son
corps avant de s'exposer au froid oui
lorsque vous avez vu dans le reportage
c'est d'ailleurs dos de mes anciens
élèves qui ont un très bon niveau
aujourd'hui c'est des expositions
extrême francs donc pour ça il faut
avoir eu un encadrement d enseignement
etc
et puis être sûr qu'on a pas de
contre-indication d'accord maintenant
pour monsieur madame tout le monde
l'exposition au froid à la méthode
wemhoff ça peut se pratiquer au
quotidien par exemple pour revenir sur
les graisses brunes le simple fait de
diminuer le chauffage chez vous la
maison le soir et de faire en sorte que
la température de la chambre à coucher
se rapproche des 18 19 degrés ce sera
très bon et pour votre santé et pour la
facture d'électricité également sans
tomber dans des températures très
froides on peut commencer à prendre des
douches
pas forcément froide métier d travailler
si de variabilité d'accord pour ça y'a
pas besoin de mots du médecin ou dect
encadrer toutes ces explications les
vidéos d'introduction elles sont
disponibles en fait sur le site de la
méthode limoges qui s'affiche
actuellement normale et
voilà c'est des choses en fait qu'on
faisait quand on était gamins et on se
posait pas la question c'est tellement
rigolo de se faire arroser et ses
dernières choses sur le froid on l'a vu
une préparation des pompes des exercices
de respiration pour faire baisser aussi
le rythme cardiaque
les personnes qui pratiquent cette
méthode on l'a vu on toujours quelque
chose sur la tête un bonnet ce que c'est
on peut perdre facilement de la chasse
et par la tête on perd le plus de
chaleur donc voilà c'est quand même plus
confortable
l'idée l'idée qu'on rentre dans le froid
n'est pas de combattre c'est d'accepter
maintenant si
voilà c'est plus confortable d'avoir un
bonnet sur la tête et que ça nous permet
de rester un peu plus longtemps dans
l'eau d'être plus cool on est un bonnet
sur la tête on a 30 secondes la méthode
en france encore peu développé cinq
instructeurs dans toute la france dans
cinq instructeurs qui sont dispatchés
dans différentes régions
et puis voilà chacun normalement fait
fait pas mal de d'explication de
publicité sur la plateforme facebook
vimov france donc ça chacun peut y aller
et puis après voilà on est en général
facilement trouvable par internet
merci à mathieu à slash est d'avoir été
avec djezzy un directeur du centre de
formation professionnelle continue en
ostéopathie d'ailleurs le site internet
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et je
rappelle que vous êtes instructeur de
cette méthode vimov dans les yvelines à
la rubrique bio hacking qui est une
façon d'utiliser ce son potentiel
naturel
c'est noté mère cissy culture génération
lully sera présenté au grand public le
15 mai prochain deux ans de travail
nécessaires à ce projet la finalité le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
et divers acteurs trappistes proposeront
une comédie ballet son nom baptiste où
l'opéra des farceurs hier soir est les
équipes présentes l évolution du
spectacle mélanie poker étaient sur
place
génération du lit prend forme petit à
petit les acteurs se découvre en
décembre dernier le champ était à
l'honneur hier soir on dansait
[Musique]
seul dans ce que tu attends ce xviie
siècle on appelle la belle danse la
danse baroque
c'est une danse qui vient elle même de
la danse traditionnelle donc ça avait
l'air à travers l'est pas mais pas si
loin que ça sous l'impulsion musicale
n'est pas si loin que ça de la danse
maroc
le cercle celtique c'est isabelle mais
aussi sept danseurs de la compagnie
black blanc beur font partie du projet
une passerelle entre différentes époques
[Musique]
de toute manière au niveau de la danse à
un partage donc si on partage pas bah
pas d'ouverture et s'il n'y a pas
d'ouverture bon ça c'est fermé sur soi
et puis c'est important aussi d'avoir à
cette forme d'ouverture en fait voilà
par rapport aux autres types de danse
plus que deux mois de préparation avant
de révéler l'opéra des farceurs le
public découvrira l'histoire de jean
baptiste lully à la merise de trappes
[Musique]
16e édition du festival à tout bout de
champ à magny les hameaux c'est jusqu'au
25 mars exposition humour concerts et
comédie musicale une programmation riche
et pour tous les publics ce jeudi matin
c'était la compagnie tous métis qui a
emmené les jeunes spectateurs sur les
rives du mississippi dans son conte
musical nola black sol
un festival qui mêle différents médiums
pour faire découvrir l'art sous toutes
ses formes
une exposition a été également réalisés
par les élèves de la ville des propos
recueillis par camille lambert et
quentin le frère on est dans la maison
d'environnement où on a une exposition
faite par les quinze classes de magny
les hameaux et qui ont accueilli
charlotte de long qui est plasticienne
qui a déjà travaillé avec nous
et elle aura fait apprendre et découvrir
surtout la méthode la vie c'est une
méthode de l'eau puisque notre thème
cette année c'est au fil de l'eau c'est
une manière d'impliquer le public que
l'on essaye de toucher
c'est un rendez vous traditionnel chaque
année à coignières la fête de la bière
se tient ce samedi à 20 heures au salon
antoine de saint-exupéry pour en parler
avec mon invité jean armel 80 bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président du comité
des fêtes de coignières c'est ce comité
des fêtes justement qui organise cet
événement déjà pour commencer pourquoi
une fête de la bière à quoi y'en a
tendance à connaître peut-être les fêtes
en bavière en alsace pourquoi la faire à
coignières cette fête bien pourquoi la
fête de la bière à coignières il faut
remonter un petit peu à la génèse dans
les années 80 90 ça s'appelait le bal de
printemps le bal de printemps et il a
connu son heure de gloire
ensuite donc il y a eu
les
comment dirais je
les bals populaires ont disparu
pratiquement de la campagne ou au profit
donc des boîtes de nuit et autres voilà
et donc mes prédécesseurs se sont posé
la question pour savoir comment on
pouvait relancer
donc ce bal du printemps et dans les
années 97 98
ils ont imaginé un petit peu une
restauration comme et la restauration de
la plus festive que l'on puisse
connaître bien c'est la choucroute avec
un verre de bière à consommer avec
modération à consommer avec modération
voilà et donc d'entrée
ça a beaucoup plu ils ont eu beaucoup
donc 2
d'invités en fin de de convives et donc
dans les années 2010
on a commencé à avoir quand même une
baisse de 2,7 des convives d'accord et
donc on s'est reposé la question à cette
période là en disant mais qu'est ce que
l'on peut imaginer pour relancer donc
cette fête de la bière
et là on a pensé aux soirées dansantes
puisque la ville de coignières
actuellement donc organise chaque mois
d après midi dansant qui fonctionne très
bien
il aura d'ailleurs un orchestre / 7 /
cette forêt voilà voilà
et donc lors qu'elles se bavarois ont la
scinder en deux parties la première
partie c'est la musique bavaroise avec
donc l'ambiance bavarois les costumes
sont canet avec les costumes bien sûr et
puis ensuite donc la deuxième partie de
soirée c'est vraiment une soirée
dansante avec un petit à faire avec leur
caisse complémentaire que les gens ont
l'habitude de connaître au niveau d d d
après midi dansant et là la fête est
relancé
alors ça environ 200 personnes chaque
année qui viennent sur sur cette fête de
la bière à votre avis pourquoi est-ce un
rendez-vous qui fonctionne à leur voler
10 et ça remonte à loin il ya des
origines y avait le bal avant bien sûr
et donc les habitants de coignières sont
attachés à ces évolutions qui arrive et
que on est obligé de s'adapter donc
à ce que veulent les convives quoi vous
avez parlé de l'orchestré bavarois du
coup on imaginait une inspiration sur
les fêtes de bière de débit requis
peuvent se dérouler en alsace en bavière
en allemagne aussi bien sûr notre
objectif c'est d'avoir une soirée
festive et donc
eh bien il faut que les gens alors on
les reçoit donc au niveau d'une table
des tables rondes ses convives la vienne
entre amis ils sont 8 10 est il réservé
une table d'accord et donc ça commence
par de la convivialité la discussion la
choucroute arrive et puis donc
l'ambiance monte haut niveau donc de
leur caisse bavarois et puis ensuite
donc ça se termine par une soirée
dansante telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui et tel que ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya un type de
bières proposées on rappelle un cloud ou
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
mais ce que c'est de la bière locale est
ce que c'est un type de bière spécifique
alors au niveau de la bière on
s'approvisionne donc chez une
une personne qui est habite coignières
d'accord et
donc c'est une bière alors c'est une
bière que l'on veut goûteuse
mais avec un degré alcoolique faibles
très bien le temps le temps file dans
cet entretien je rappelle que c'est
organisé par le comité des fêtes de
coignières qu'est ce qu'il faut savoir
sur ce comité des fêtes quel type
d'événement il organise à croyait alors
qu'il y a donc également la fête de
coignières d'accord qui se déroule fin
juin et puis ensuite on a donc à l'auto
et
et le marché de noël que l'on organise
également avec la commune de coignières
beaucoup d'événements bas merci jean
armel 4 loin d'être venu parler de cette
fête de la bière avec nous je rappelle
vous êtes le présent du comité des fêtes
de coignières est donc cette fête de la
bière à coignières se tient ce samedi à
20h et c'est au salon antoine de
saint-exupéry vous pouvez retrouver les
informations sur le site de la ville de
coignard avant de se quitter je vous en
parlais dans les titres de cet événement
pour les amateurs de bateaux et de train
en miniature une exposition modélisme et
à vivre ce week end à montigny le
bretonneux deux clubs de la ville
s'unissent pour l'occasion mélanie poker
et camille lambert ont rencontré à ces
associations lors des derniers
préparatifs regard des derniers essais
avant le jour j les passionnés du train
finalisent leur installation 50 mètres
carrés de réseaux ferroviaires
entièrement créés par ce club de
modélisme un loisir partagé par 32
adhérents aux compétences variées
on a besoin de faire de la menuiserie de
la peinture électricité de lektronix
suivant les compétences de chacun nous
ne sommes pas limités à dans certains
clubs à une époque particulière à
une région particulière donc chacun même
ses trains donc à biot tout du tout type
et des ter des vapeurs voilà tu peux
tout une installation visibles les 17 et
18 mars lors d'une exposition commune
avec les amis des flots l'association de
modélisme naval cette fois à
l'initiative de ce projet ces passionnés
mettent plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années pour réaliser leur bateau j'ai
fabriqué de toutes pièces
l'ensemble du bateau ce n'est pas la
sienne pas une boîte de construction il
a fait que je découpe les morceaux de
bois travaillé entre autres la résine
par exemple à la dérive un futur voilier
télécommandé qui ne sera pas exposée
mais les visiteurs pourront tester
d'autres créations similaires moi j'aime
bien voir mes bateaux naviguent et
ensuite nous aurons un bassin pour
pouvoir faire une initiation avec les
enfants ou les parents d'ailleurs
d'après télé la radio commandés ils
pourront naviguer sur le petit bassin
qu'on leur mettra à disposition de quoi
devenir capitaine ou voyager en wagon le
temps d'une journée sans quitter les
yvelines c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi au programme ce
soir sur notre chaîne comme chaque jeudi
c'est le 7-8 débat présenté par amanda
bherer rivera entouré de ses invités
thème ce soir les inégalités salariales
entre les femmes et les hommes cette
édition elle est à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]